amid conflicting reports today regarding
Noah's condition Michael Buble and his
wife Luisana released this joint
statement on their Facebook page this
morning we are so grateful to report
that our son Noah has been progressing
well during his treatment and the
doctors are very optimistic about the
future for our little boy he's been
brave throughout and we continue to be
inspired by his courage our gratitude to
his doctors and caretakers cannot be put
into words we'd also like to thank the
thousands of people that have sent their
prayers and good wishes to us hello we
do Canada BT Canada Canada no is
currently fighting cancer in the United
States after being diagnosed last
November daddy's gonna talk to you nice
to meet you I recently sat down with
Michael onset of his nobody but me music
video where he told me how parenting has
changed his life the best part about
being a parent was that it taught me
perspective and it allowed me to know
what was really important for me and
which in a way allowed me to enjoy my
job since the shocking news was
announced Michael and his wife stepped
out of the spotlight cancelling numerous
public appearances including his hosting
gig at this month's Brit Awards he's
also said to host the Juno Awards on
April 2nd but no word yet if he'll take
the stage for Canadian music's biggest
night